[Music]
tomorrow is election day as you know
it's the day that you decide whether for
the next four years we make jokes about
president Mitt Romney or jokes about
former governor Mitt Romney that's your
call it's really that's good to see you
[Applause]
[Music]
that's me voting the big lever yeah I've
never voted with the big lever anyone
here voted with the big lever have you
done that okay three of you even that
got a woo yeah I'm talking about voting
in 1944 that's what I'm pull a big route
yeah yeah check this out gang in Florida
the lines for early voting are nine
hours long
nine hours which is too bad because it's
Florida a lot of those people don't have
nine hours that you like okay
it's a pro death crap I've heard about
this in Ohio yesterday a man who heckled
President Obama was carried away by four
police officers
yeah not cuz he was a danger but because
anytime you carry a person from Ohio you
need four people they hate the elderly
and fat people yeah there is good news
check this out the end of the election
means that negative political ads will
finally stop after tomorrow the only two
people attacking each other on TV will
be Nicki Minaj and Mariah Carey this
weekend Bristol Palin's baby daddy Levi
Johnston married the mother of his new
baby and he wore camouflage at the
ceremony yeah I guess Levi wanted his
wife and new baby to get used to not
seeing him
why would you wear camouflage that makes
no sense I don't know maybe a bear was
gonna attack her love to attack weddings
I don't know who went to the movies but
the Disney animated movie wreck-it Ralph
was tops at the box office yeah a lot of
kids were disappointed because wreck-it
Ralph is about Ralph Nader in the 2000
election why is it animate I don't you
saw this last week the Mars rover
stretched out its robotic arm and took a
picture of itself in other words
America's greatest technological
achievement has turned into a 14-year
old girl with Instagram
[Applause]
check me out check out my new top I'm
worried about what other photos will
start coming in Oh Rove oh sorry that
was Matt guys for you
I told you not to show anyone else Rover
doesn't speak so stupid in Austin Texas
a brawl broke out involving 17 strippers
[Applause]
so regardless of what happens tomorrow
America is still the greatest country on
Earth
[Applause]
[Music]